this video is proudly sponsored by
squarespace
the squat is a movement that doesn't get
the love that it definitely deserves
people do tons of push-ups and pull-ups
but the squat which is kind of like the
leg equivalent of a push-up pull-up
doesn't get anywhere near the same
attention and that's a massive shame
because the squat is actually the one
that i think people need the most out of
these exercises people love it in the
gym if they compile loads of weight on
their back apparently they don't think
it has the same value when performed
with only body weight this is a huge
shame because the body weight squat on
its own can address so many different
issues with mobility with pain with
discomfort and it can improve your
athletic performance this is something
that we should be doing every single day
and that's something that more and more
coaches are now recommending of course
the likes of ido portal and i highly
agree with it this one movement can
reduce pain it can improve mobility it
can reduce your chances of injury it can
make you faster help you jump higher
make you more athletic can make you feel
more youthful and more invigorated
now the idea of doing anything every
single day might be setting off alarm
bells and rightly so often these are
used as kind of hacks and cheats to try
and brute force your way into a certain
result you know i did 100 push-ups every
single day it's a great clickable
thumbnail and so was this to be fair but
i'm not talking about doing hundreds of
squats every single day i'm simply
talking about getting into a squat
position a resting squat sometimes it's
called a primal squat or a deep squat
every single day and that's something
that i safely can recommend
once you've built up to the ability to
do it and as long as you don't have any
issues that prevent you from doing it
healthily because this is something that
we've evolved to be able to do the
squatting position is how we would rest
in the absence of a chair it's how we
defecate it's how women would give birth
in some cases and so it's a position
that we're supposed to be able to be in
this is what we've got to look at when
we're looking at our performance the way
we feel it's not just what movements can
we do it's what basic movements are
missing from our routines that we would
have gotten and that our body clearly
needs so if you're not already a
movement practitioner if you're not
someone who does this regularly then you
might find that you struggle to even get
into a deep squat position and this is a
good example of why we need it so much
so if you try and get down into a
resting squat like this
and then you struggle you might find
that one of several things is happening
either you find yourself feeling like
you're going to tip backwards that's
slightly due to an issue with your ankle
mobility you're struggling with
dorsiflexion therefore your center of
gravity needs to be more forwards you
end up rolling backwards it might be an
issue with knee pain or knee mobility
because if you look your knees are bent
all the way might be an issue with your
spine because this puts a stretch on the
bottom of the spine in particular which
is something so many of us could do with
or you might find that your toes want to
splay outwards that your knees start
caving in or your feet start caving in
this is due to hip mobility issues we
need a little bit of internal rotation
or to keep the toes pointing fairly
forwards when we stand up
we're using external rotation to drive
ourselves upwards and keep the knees and
the ankles all nicely in line
you might finally get a little bit of
butt wink this can happen if your hip
sockets are too deep which means that
when your femur moves upwards like that
it actually causes your pelvis to tuck
underneath it's like you're tucking up
your tailbone the solution to this is to
move your legs slightly out more for a
lot of people this can address that
issue however then you're going to need
a little bit more hip mobility of course
there's no one perfect way to squat and
each person is going to look slightly
different you might find you need to
lean more forwards or you might need to
find that you can easily stay more
upright however should be rounding the
back ideally you want to keep the spine
straight still we're just going to lean
forwards a little bit your feet should
be pointing roughly forwards but it
doesn't have to be exact you don't want
them splayed out like this unless you're
gonna do some kind of sumo squat or plie
but if you just twist them out slightly
that's fine of course you got into this
mess because you never have to squat in
your daily life you spend so long
sitting in that position with your spine
supported probably with an unnatural
curvature glute's deactivated all this
means that you now struggle to get into
a basic squat position but more than
that it means you're stiff and awkward
as you move around throughout the day
and squatting to some extent is a simple
fact of life whether you're getting up
out of the couch if you find that
difficult then working on your squat
could help a lot if you're squatting a
bit to pick something up you're more
likely to round your spine if you have a
weaker core which means you're more
likely to injure yourself if you're
running if you're jumping you're less
likely to keep your knees and your
ankles aligned especially when you're
jumping when getting into that counter
movement can be useful depending on the
activity the easier it is for you to
drop down the more you can spring right
back up and jump super high this is
going to unlock more athletic
performance therefore and liam ellis the
parkour guy that i've trained with a
couple of times told me how important a
deep squat is for parkour because it
allows you to land really nice and
easily the ability to get into a really
deep squat means it's going to be easier
for you to get into a more shallow squat
and to control that movement downwards
in short after practicing this for a
while on a daily basis you'll wake up in
the morning with more energy more vigor
feeling more youthful more ready to take
on the day
and now let's take a moment to talk
about today's sponsor squarespace if you
want to build a website squarespace is
your best bet this is a powerful tool
that creates sites that look modern
attractive and professional it's easy to
use with no coding required
turn your passion into a business with a
number of professional features such as
gated members only content for easy
monetization with member management
email communications and audience
insights
there's an integrated commenting system
with support for threaded comments
replies and likes blogging tools of
course for publishing content
categorizing and scheduling posts and
more
plus social media integration to display
posts from your social profiles on your
site or push social media content
automatically
there are powerful ecommerce
capabilities for selling goods too
additional third-party extensions
provide inventory management marketing
streamline to bookkeeping sales tax
reconciliation and filing and logistics
for global shipping and when you're
ready to launch bioneer viewers can get
10 off the purchase of their first
website or domain by going to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
today
and now on with the show
and that's the really good news this is
really easy to fix and solve all you
need to do to get better mobility in all
these areas is to practice the resting
squat but of course we need to do this
correctly if you're squatting
incorrectly then you're only going to
exacerbate these issues and make them
worse and of course if you're someone
who even struggles to get into this
position then we need to use
progressions to work up to it gently in
a safe and healthy manner so one of the
easiest ways to start out learning to
squat if you struggle to do it at the
moment is to use some kind of
counterbalance something to hold on to
and this can help you control the
movement down and back up at the same
time it's going to prevent you from
tipping backwards and you can even apply
a little bit of pressure to ease into
that ankle mobility so just hold on to
railing someone's hand a chair whatever
you've got lying around
and then just
squat down
holding on and then you can practice
keeping your core up helping yourself
more or less and that's a really great
way to work on that mobility gently if
you could only go down this far before
your knee starts to hurt then just go
down that far we don't want to work
through pain at any point you should be
able to feel the difference between
discomfort from stretching and actual
pain and of course the very best way to
do this safely and without exacerbating
any existing injuries is to speak to
someone in person who can look at you
who can look at your unique biomechanics
and your medical history and help you to
do this in a safe way however for those
that don't have any problems this is a
nice easy way to get yourself back into
that very natural movement pattern
another way you can make it slightly
easier if you do have tight calves and
struggle with ankle mobility is to prop
your heels up on something slightly like
a squat block a weight plate in the gym
or even just a stick or rock that you
find even just a slight incline if
you're out and about that make it easier
to get into that position without a lot
of dorsiflexion then you want to reduce
the amount of help you're getting by
lowering and lowering the amount of rays
you have on the heels and eventually you
want to work all the way up
to doing it with barefoot shoes because
this is another reason that we have
these issues in the first place because
we walk around with shoes that have big
heels on we never need that kind of
range of motion everything tightens up
and if you're struggling with the squat
and you want a real practical functional
way to practice it then another great
easier progression is just sitting down
and standing up just find yourself a
bench or something like that sit down
stand up
this is a great way to limit mobility to
something you're comfortable with
but at the same time you're working
strength in many of the same areas
boom now i'm in this place of course you
can also improve your squat mobility and
strength by isolating specific areas
that are causing you trouble a great
example would be to work on the glute
medius by doing hip abduction
alternatively you might want to open up
the ankles a little bit more by
stretching the calves you can do it
through elephant walks i made a whole
video on ankle mobility and stability
really recently which nobody watched so
go and check that one out if you want to
learn a bit more about how to do that if
you find it okay getting in this
position but you feel you could use a
little bit more hip mobility then a
great option is to use the press squat
you get down like this put your hands
together and then use your elbows to
drive your knees apart slightly it's
really hard to overstate just how
valuable
practicing and resting squat really is
apparently if you start training with
the movement guru eda portal one of the
first things he'll get you to do is
practice squatting for 30 minutes a day
a great benchmark used by a lot of
coaches is to see if you can comfortably
squat for 10 minutes in the go if you
get to this point then you'll find it
opens up so much more freedom of
movement and power and confidence it's
game changing in terms of the way you
feel and the way you performed once
you've got that range of motion that
movement passing you're happy with it
and you're not feeling any pain now you
can start repping out high repetition
bodyweight squats and these are
fantastic for building up your legs
building power explosiveness and working
on that mobility keeping it there at the
same time so you might think that if you
can squat a whole load at the gym then
there's no point doing high repetition
bodyweight squats as you'll know if
you've watched this channel for any
length of time i highly recommend lower
weight higher rep for a range of
specific benefits for one you've got
strength endurance being able to lift
something really heavy once is not as
useful as being able to lift something
quite heavy a lot of times
the thing is you don't actually need
really heavy weight to build strength if
you go to failure then you'll fatigue
the slow twitch muscle fibers which will
force the faster twitch muscle fibers to
kick in again we need continual time
under tension for this to work you don't
build as much strength as you would with
a heavy barbell of course but you could
build a lot of strength and at the same
time you'll be getting all of that
strength endurance which is so useful
when you're using your legs in a real
world scenario
and of course as you're wrapping these
out you're also getting all of those
mobility benefits the core strength and
just cementing those newer pathways so
you can drop down more powerfully and
with more stability and because using
very high repetitions particularly with
a high continuous time and attention can
cause blood to pull in the muscles this
is also great for vascularization it can
increase blood vessels and blood supply
to the muscle and then there's studies
that show a correlation between this and
an increased satellite cell count and
myonuclei count these are really
important for protein synthesis muscle
growth and they're particularly useful
because they stick around even when your
muscle atrophies
the obvious example that comes to mind
is prisoner training prisoners famously
use only basic bodyweight exercises to
build massive physiques lots of power
and a great example of a prisoner who
did this was mike tyson who reportedly
used lots of bodyweight squats he would
gamify this by using cards and picking
them off the ground and he built massive
legs this way and when he returned to
fighting this gave him more power to
drive through with his punches
if you want the benefits of the high
repetition squats but you don't want the
stress that this can place on the knees
in the back if you're not ready for it
yet then you can elevate the heels and
this will give you that great deep squat
that you can use for high repetitions
and with minimal risk of pain or
problems another really good variation
is the hindu squat here you're on the
balls of your feet and you're squatting
down allowing your knees to go past your
toes this is a fantastic exercise again
because this is one of the ways that we
squat in real life you go down to play
with your kids you'll probably be up on
your toes just can't hold this position
for as long you also run off of your
toes and sprint and jump so if you want
to develop power for sports and
athleticism then really you need to be
able to perform from this position as
well the [ __ ] squat takes this even
further you lean back in order to create
a longer lever arm with your body and
then perform the squat on your toes like
that this is really good for
strengthening the knees but you
shouldn't do this if you have any
current knee issues you have to work up
to this one
the pistol squat of course puts all your
weight on one side and challenges you to
balance through the movement really test
your mobility because if you have any
issues here you're going to fall
backwards and it's a great exercise as
well i won't go into huge depth right
now talking about all the different
variations there after the squat because
a lot of these i'll make videos on in
future i'll definitely be covering the
hindu squat i'll probably cover the
pistol squat let me know if you guys
would like to see me cover any others in
future as well
i hope you found this video useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like and share around that's helped me
out immensely let me know in the
comments down below if you perform a
squat every single day whether you do
the resting squat whether you just do
higher repetitions of bodyweight squats
what works best for you if you like this
kind of training and philosophy that
looks at all around performance not just
strength or aesthetics but mobility
balance strength explosiveness even
focus and brain power then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program and
full video course super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system there's a link to that in the
description down below so over two hours
of video tutorials along with a in-depth
pdf either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys i appreciate it
massively and
bye for now